♪ ♪
>> Dagen: BETO O'ROURKE IS
DESPERATELY TRYING TO REBOOT HIS
CAMPAIGN AFTER BOTTOMING OUT IN
THE POLLS, BUT IT IS NOT GOING
SO WELL.
AFTER BOMBING ON "THE VIEW" AND
APOLOGIZING FOR HIS PRIVILEGE,
HE DECIDED TO GET BACK TO ITS
ROOTS.
REMEMBER WHEN HE LIVE STREAMED
HIS TRIP TO THE DENTIST.
LUCKY FOR US, BETO IS BACK WITH
ANOTHER BIZARRE VIDEO.
CHECK THIS OUT.
>> CUTTING OUT SOME OF THIS YEAR
HERE THAT YOU GET WHEN YOU GET
OLDER.
IF YOU DO NOT GET IT CUT, IT CAN
BE NASTY.
>> Dana: THAT IS PROBABLY
TRUE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dagen: AGAIN, THERE IS A
FINE LINE BETWEEN GOOFY AND
UNCONFIDENT.
>> Dana: IT IS 0-100 IN ABOUT
20 SECONDS.
THE DEMOCRATS REALLY WANT HIM TO
STAY IN TEXAS AND RUN FOR SENATE
AGAINST CORN AND, BECAUSE HE HAD
TAKEN ON TED CRUZ, AND HE DID
NOT REALLY COME THAT CLOSE AGAIN
NOT REALLY COME THAT CLOSE AGAIT
NOT REALLY COME THAT CLOSE AGAID
NOT REALLY COME THAT CLOSE AGAIC
NOT REALLY COME THAT CLOSE AGAIU
NOT REALLY COME THAT CLOSE AGAI,
NOT REALLY COME THAT CLOSE AGAIB
NOT REALLY COME THAT CLOSE AGAIT
NOT REALLY COME THAT CLOSE AGAIC
NOT REALLY COME THAT CLOSE AGAIO
NOT REALLY COME THAT CLOSE AGAIH
NOT REALLY COME THAT CLOSE AGAIN
OTHER DEMOCRATS.
AND NOW I THINK IT HAS BECOME
PRETTY CLEAR THAT HE MIGHT BE
GOOD AT RUNNING FOR SENATE, BUT
NOT GOOD AT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT AND NOT WITH THIS
CROWD.
>> Greg: TRYING TO MAKE
HIMSELF SEEM REAL AND AUTHENTIC,
AND EVERY TIME YOU DO THAT, YOU
COME OFF LOOKING DESPERATE AND
THIRSTY.
YOU SHOULD BE HAPPY THAT HE
MARRIED UP AND RICH AND STOP
PARADING HIS MYRIAD OF FLAWS TO
THE EMBARRASSMENT OF ALL.
"THE VIEW" ORDERED THE KILL SHOT
AND TRAINED HIM INTO A SCHOOL
BOY WHOSE JACKET DID NOT FIT.
AND A BETO MALE WHO WILL WRITE
ABOUT IT IN HIS DREAM JOURNAL.
WOMEN KNOW THIS GUY FROM
COLLEGE, HE LURES YOU IN THE
DORM WITH THE ILLUSION OF DEPTH,
THE COLLECTION OF CAMUS AND
POETRY.
>> Dagen: WILLIAM BLAKE IN THE
DORM.
>> Greg: WHY DID I WASTE MY
TIME?
>> Dagen: YOU COULD PLAY HIM
IN A MOVIE, JESSE.
>> Jesse: THANKS.
>> Dagen: WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
BETO?
IT IS IN YOUR BEST INTEREST TO
HAVE HIM HAVE A LONG RUN.
>> Jesse: THAT IS TRUE.
I THINK THAT OTHER PEOPLE ASSUME
THAT THEY THINK THAT THEY ARE
INTERESTING AND THAT IS NOT THE
CASE, SOMETIMES YOU DON'T WANT
TO SEE WHAT IS UNDER THE HOOD OR
HOW THE SAUSAGE IS MADE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GO BEHIND THE
CURTAIN, ALWAYS.
SOMETIMES THE CURTAIN IS
THEREFORE A REASON.
IT IS A REALITY SHOW THAT HE IS
RUNNING, NOT A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
I READ THE "VANITY FAIR" PIECE
TODAY, AND THIS WOMAN SAID THAT
BETO REMINDS ALL AMERICAN WOMEN
ABOUT A BAD BOYFRIEND THEY HAVE
HAD.
AND I THINK THAT THIS IS PRETTY
MUCH THE CASE.
POLITICIANS ARE SUCCESSFUL WHEN
THEY USE IMAGERY WELL TO ENHANCE
THEIR LOOK.
THE IMAGE OF HIM WITH HIS MOUTH
HANGING OPEN OR HIS WET HAIR
OVER HIS FOREHEAD, OR THE AIR
HAIR, THOSE IMAGES RIGHT THERE,
THEY ARE THE KIND OF
PRESIDENTIAL IMAGES THAT DOOM
ANY CAMPAIGN.
IT IS LIKE HE IS VOLUNTEERING TO
PUT THE DUKAKIS HELMET ON IN THE
TANK AND HE THINKS THAT IT IS
WINNING.
>> Dagen: JUAN.
[LAUGHS]
>> Juan: IN THIS CURRENT
ITERATION OF AMERICAN POLITICS
IN 2020, SOCIAL MEDIA AND
AUTHENTICITY ARE A REALLY
INTERESTING DYNAMIC MIX.
YOU SEE PEOPLE DOING THIS STUFF,
AND LIFTING WEIGHTS, AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
SO RIGHT NOW, HE IS NOT DOING
THAT WELL IN THE POLLS, HE
DEBATES WELL ON THE DEBATE
STAGE, BUT HE IS NOT RISING.
AND PART OF THIS IS INTERESTING,
WHERE HE IS WINNING IS ON
INSTAGRAM.
HE HAS THE BIGGEST INSTAGRAM
FOLLOWING OF ANYBODY.
AND THAT IS A YOUNGER GROUP OF
PEOPLE, AND APPARENTLY THEY LIKE
THIS.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT
REPRESENTS THE UNIVERSE OF
DEMOCRATS IN THE COUNTRY,
OBVIOUSLY.
YOU SEE BIDEN RISING.
YOU SEE PETE BUTTIGIEG TAKING A
LOT OF HIS STEAM, BECAUSE I
THINK THAT PETE BUTTIGIEG IS NOT
RUNNING A SOCIAL MEDIA CAMPAIGN.
HE IS RUNNING A NATIONAL
CAMPAIGN PRAYED HE DOES BETTER
ON "THE VIEW" BETTER ON "LN."
TO BE ON HIS GAME IS STRONG
BECAUSE OF HIS HUSBAND AND THIRD
TWO DOGS THAT HAVE THEIR OWN
INSTAGRAM ACCOUNT, PEOPLE WOULD
VOTE FOR THOSE TWO DOGS OVER
BETO O'ROURKE AT THIS POINT.
>> Jesse: YOU SHOULD NOT BE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT OF
INSTAGRAM OR TWITTER.
>> Greg: DID I SAY THAT?
I DON'T THINK IT WAS ME.
>> Jesse: YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> Dagen: HOW LONG BEFORE IT
DROPS OUT?